THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. ACOSTA.
AND WE ARE CURRY.
ALLEN.
ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA.
BURKE.
CABALLERO.
CALDERON.
CARILLO.
SO BONTA THIS
CHAO.
SHOPPERS.
GEN.
DAVID CHIU.
JURY CHIU.
COOLEY.
COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM.
DALLEY.
DALY.
EGGMAN.
FLORA.
FONG.
FRAZIER.
FRIEDMAN.
GALLAGHER.
CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GLORIA.
BEEN GRAY.
GRAYSON.
HARPER.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
JONES SAWYER.
KALRA.
KILEY.
LACKEY.
LEVINE.
WE KNOW.
LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MATHIS.
MAYES MEDINA.
MELENDEZ MULLIN.
MURATSUCHI.
THIS AREA.
OBERNOLTE.
O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON.
QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA.
REYES
RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO
SELLERS
SANTIAGO STONE.
BERMAN.
TING.
VOEPEL.
WALDRON.
WEBER.
WOOD. MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK THAT OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER.
AND IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THE DAYS PRAYER.
WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR GUEST
CHAPLAIN.
RABBI KANTOR A LOT OUT ROSE IN
BROWN OF CONGREGATION RODEF
SHALOM. IN SAN RAFAEL RABBI
ROSEN BROWN.
JURU. HAKKA FOOD SHANTIES WELL.
YEAH I OF. ITS. I OF MOVE.
SHARIA.
HE TO LOVE LOVE.
EARNS SURE IS.
MMHM. LOVE BLOOM AND HAVE MOVED.
GUYS WHO YOU KNOW HOW GOV.
GOOD FOR.-.
YEAH.
MOVIES HE.
WHO'LL.
BLESSED IS THE MATCH CONSUMED IN
KINDLING FIRE.
BLESSED IS THE FLAME THAT BURNS
IN THE HEARTS SECRET PLACES
BLESSED IS THE HEART WITH
STRENGTH TO STOP BEATING.
FOR HONOR SAKE.
SOURCE OF LIFE COMPASSIONATE
ONE.
WE RECITE THE WORDS OF THIS POEM
THIS BLESSING ASHTRAY HUNGER FOR
LOWER BY HANNAH SENATE SHAUN
THIS DAY. IN MEMORY OF THE SIX
MILLION JEWS WHO WERE MURDERED
BY THE* DURING THE HOLOCAUST.
THE MEMORIES OF THESE SIX
MILLION MEN WOMEN AND CHILDREN
WERE NOT IN VAIN.
AND NEVER WILL BE.
THEIR MEMORIES LIVE STORIES
SONGS AND SOULS CONTINUE TO
LIGHT OUR PATHS FORWARD THROUGH
HISTORY.
AND TOWARDS TRUTH.
LIKE A KINDLING FLAME.
WE WILL NEVER FORGET YOU.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO TELL YOUR
STORIES.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO HONOR YOUR
NAMES.
YOUR LEGACIES ARE A STAMP.
BURNED ON OUR HEARTS.
SIX MILLION TIMES STRONGER THAN
THE NUMBERS WITH WHICH YOUR ARMS
WERE BRANDED.
YOU.
AND EVERY SURVIVOR HERE WHOM WE
HONOR.
YOU ARE A CONSTANT REMINDER.
CALLING US TO CONSCIENCE.
AND CALLING US TO ACTION.
IN YOUR MEMORY.
WE WILL KEEP OUR PASSION FOR
ROAD F. PSAMTIK PURSUING JUSTICE
BURNING.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO EXAMINE OUR
OWN BIAS SEASON SERVICE TO
ACTING WITH DEEPER COMPASSION
TOWARDS OTHERS.
WE WILL WORK TIRELESSLY TO
EDUCATE OUR YOUTH TO EMBRACE AND
PROCLAIM LOVE AND UNDERSTANDING
OF EVERY PERSON REGARDLESS OF
RACE RELIGION ETHNICITY GENDER
SEXUAL ORIENTATION OR COUNTRY OF
ORIGIN.
WE WILL TEACH REVERENCE FOR AND
REMEMBRANCE OF HISTORY IN
SERVICE OF WISDOM TRUTH.
AND IN SERVICE OF THE GREATER
GOOD.
WE WILL PLEDGE OURSELVES TO TURN
TOWARDS RATHER THAN AWAY FROM
HUMAN PAIN AND SUFFERING AND TO
RAISE OUR VOICES AND OPEN OUR
HEARTS TO ALL IN NEED.
WE WILL CREATE THE KIND OF
WORLDS IN WHICH EVERY SINGLE
INDIVIDUALS BASIC NEEDS AND
VALUES CAN THRIVE.
ON THIS DAY OF REMEMBRANCE.
I DON'T I.
SOURCE OF LIFE.
I CALL OUT TO YOU.
BLESS THIS ASSEMBLY OF PEOPLE.
SURVIVORS AND THEIR LOVED ONES.
LEGISLATORS.
LEADERS OF OUR COMMUNITY.
BLESS US WITH WISDOM AND
COURAGE.
THAT WE MAY HAVE THE STRENGTH
AND DISCERNMENT TO DO OUR WORK.
AND LIVE OUR LIVES WITH WORDS OF
KINDNESS
ALWAYS ON OUR LIPS.
AND THE FLAME OF JUSTICE.
ANIMATING OUR HEARTS.
A STRAY HOOKUP THROUGH OR.
MAY WE ALL BE BLESSED
WITH THE HEART OF STRENGTH.
THAT CONTINUES TO BEAT.
FROM NOW UNTIL ETERNITY.
FOR THE SAKE.
OF HONOR.
ATKINS TENURE STANDING NOW IN
HONOR OF THE SIX MILLION.
FOR THE MEMORIAL PRAYER.
MLA RUSSELL MEANS.
I OF.
HUMN.
HOME IT SOON EN.
TIME NOW HAN.
.
TELL US WHAT KIND.
MMHM.
HYMNBOOKS.
MAS HUGE WHO.
MMHM
AT NEW SMART SHE SAID HOW MANY
ON US.
HELLO. WELL IF YOU'D.
NONNA.
YEAH.
THE.
.
MMHM.
HE.
THE.
STATE.
IT'S SO OWES THE OF HUMN.
NASH WANT THE.
.
THEN MOVES WHO. SHALL RULE.
HOMELESS GO ALONG.
I OF.
THE US.
.
THANK YOU RABBI.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
TO REMAIN STANDING.
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER BERMAN.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE FLAG
SALUTE.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
IT IS.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY MARCH TWENTY
SECOND TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE
SUMMIT NINETY ON THE ON THE
LOWER FRIEDMAN.
TO PROTECT THE SCENE BECAUSE I'D
SECRETLY DAWSON WAS METASTASIS
INCLUDE BABY BOOMER READING
ROLES CALL ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
SHOPPERS WITH A CORPORAL YOU
SIMPLY KNOW SHUDDER CALDERON
MOVES AND MISS WALDRON SECONDS.
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL WILL BE DISPENSED
WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY.
FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
SURVIVE TESTS WE ARE MOVING TO
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE ONE EIGHTEEN NAY
TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS CALLED
RUN WITH AND THE VENA HAVE GAS
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR
TODAY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE'S GUEST
WILL BE IN THE AREA OF THE
MEMBERS DESKS FOR THE HOLOCAUST
REMEMBRANCE CEREMONY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA AS GUESTS WILL BE
SEATED AT HIS DESK.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I ALSO REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FIFTY SIX TO ALLOW THE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE. TO NOTICE
THE FOLLOWING BILLS FOR THEIR
APRIL TWENTY THIRD HEARING AB
TWENTY TWO AWAY AGUIAR CURRY
PENDING WE REFERRAL FROM THE
UTILITIES AND ENERGY COMMITTEE.
AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY AGUIAR
CURRY PENDING WE WERE FOR ALL
FROM THE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE AND AB
TWENTY NINE TWENTY THREE. CHIU
PENDING RE REFER OFTEN THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY SIX AND JOIN
WILL SUCCEED TO WEIGH THE FILE
NOTICE REQUIREMENT. TO ALLOW THE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE TO HEAR THE FOLLOWING
BILLS AT THEIR APRIL EIGHTEENTH
HEARING. AB TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTEEN IRWIN PENDING REFERRAL
FROM THE PRIVACY CONSUMER
PROTECTION COMMITTEE AND AB
TWENTY NINE FOURTEEN COOLEY
PENDING WE WERE. PENNY RE
REFERRAL A REFERRAL FROM THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE AN NUMBER OF
SPECIAL GAS WITH US.
IN THE CHAMBER TODAY
.
MISTER KALRA.
YOU HAVE A SPECIAL GUEST ON THE
FLOOR YOU ARE.
THINK THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
THINK A NUMBER YOU HAVE THE
CHANCE TO MEET MY FATHER IS WHO
HERE WITH ME AGAIN SET THEIR
KALRA.
MY IN SO PLEASE WHENEVER YOU
GET A CHANCE AS THEY COME BY AND
SAY HELLO HE ALWAYS LOVE SAY HI
TO ALL OF YOU
MEMBERS OF I COULD HAVE YOUR
ATTENTION WE HAVE ADDITIONAL GAS
WITH US. SEPARATE FROM OUR
SPECIAL CEREMONY.
WHO ARE IN THE CHAMBER?
TO PATTERSON YOU HAVE SOME GUEST
WITH US TODAY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER.
I WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE OUR
CONSTITUENTS OUT FROM MY
DISTRICT THAT DEBORAH GABRIELLE.
BUT SHE IS A TEACHER AT OUR LADY
OF VICTORY SCHOOL IN FRESNO.
SHE HAS ACCOMPANIED BY HER
STUDENTS WHO ARE IN THE FIFTH
GRADE. THEIR HERE VISITING AS
PART OF THE SOCIAL SCIENCE
CURRICULUM STUDENTS ARE
CURRENTLY STUDYING. AND TO BE
INTRODUCED TO THE SEAT OF STATE
GOVERNMENT AND HOW IT WORKS
PLEASE WELCOME THE SPOKES
PROBLEMS UP TO CALIFORNIA. RIGHT
.
AND MISTER HARPER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GAS
INTRODUCTION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER I'M VERY
PROUD TODAY TO BE ABLE
INTRODUCED.
THE SURFING DELEGATION
MY HOME
CITY HUNTINGTON BEACH
SURF CITY USA.
HERE TODAY IS POLITICAL
LEADERSHIP AS WELL AS FULL COME
VISIT HP AND THE INTERNATIONAL
SURFING MUSEUM IN HUNTINGTON
BEACH.
THERE HEARING TODAY IN SUPPORT
OF SCR ONE TWENTY TWO WHICH WAS
HEARD IN THE SENATE TODAY.
OF WITH THEM TODAY WAS UP.
MAYOR MIKE POSING FOR THE CITY
HUNTINGTON BEACH ALSO MY FRIEND
ADAN MCALLISTER FAR FORMER
HUNTINGTON BEACH MEMBER. AND ONE
OF THE GREATEST THE BOOSTERS OF
SURFING WITHIN THE CITY ALSO
DIADEM THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE INTERNATIONAL SURFING MUSEUM
IN HUNTINGTON BEACH. WHICH IS
HOME OF THE GUINNESS.
BOOK RECORD HOLDING SURFBOARD
WHICH HAD THE MOST SURFERS ANA
AND ALSO OF THE ORGANIZED THE
LARGEST PANEL OUT OF WHICH IS
RECOGNIZED BY THE GUINNESS
ORGANIZATION AS WELL. ALSO IS
JERICHO POPLAR A TRUE SURFING
PIONEER WHO BECAME THE U. S.
WOMEN'S CHAMPION IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY AND THEN CO FOUNDED THE
WOMEN'S INTERNATIONAL SURFING
ASSOCIATION. AND WENT ON TO WIN
THE FIRST WOMAN'S YOU WORLD PRO
SURFING TOUR IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
SIX AND WAS LATER INDUCTED IN
THE SURFERS HALL OF FAME IN
HUNTINGTON BEACH IN TWO THOUSAND
FOUR. ALSO WITH US IS PAUL
STRAUCH AN INFLUENTIAL LEGENDARY
SURFER OF THE NINETEEN SIXTIES
WHO PERHAPS IS BEST KNOWN FOR
THE PAUL SCROUNGE FIVE OR THAT
SHOOTER FIVE MANEUVER. IN A
SMOOTH GRACEFUL STYLE BOTH IN
AND OUT OF THE WATER HE WAS ONE
OF THE FOUR RIDERS ON THE DUKE
KAHANAMOKU SURF TEAM. AND
FINALLY ONE OF THE MOST WELL
KNOWN FOLKS.
THAT YOU CAN ASSOCIATE WITH
HUNTINGTON BEACH AT ALL IS DEAN
TORRENCE HERE.
AND OF COURSE MANY AND BOUGHT
ALL THE PEOPLE HERE KNOW THAT IN
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE THE LOS
ANGELES DUO OF JAN AND DEAN
RECORDED SIR CITY A SONG CO
WRITTEN SONG WITH THE BEACH
BOYS.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING THE HUNTINGTON BEACH
SURF CITY USA DELEGATION
AND MR STONE YOUR GUESTS HAVE
ARRIVED IN THE CHAMBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. YES THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER UP IN THE GALLERY ON THE
NORTH SIDE OR A NUMBER OF SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS FROM SANTA CRUZ
HIM BENITO IN MONTEREY COUNTY.
THERE REPRESENT IS FROM A NUMBER
OF SOME OF THE. BEST SCHOOLS IN
THE STATE SO WELCOME FOLKS FROM
ACTS OUR REGION TEN
.
MEMBERS WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
SPECIAL ASSEMBLY CEREMONY FOR
HOLOCAUST MEMORIAL DAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL MOVE
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER SIXTY NINE
EACH YEAR TO A SEVEN FRIEDMAN
FOR THE PURPOSE OF THIRD
READING.
IS FRIEDMAN ARE YOU READY
PROCEED ON THE ITEM.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME ENCOURAGE LUCIA TOOL SEVEN
BY SOME MEMBER FRIEDMAN OTHERS
RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA HOLOCAUST
MEMORIAL WE.
THIS FRIEDMAN YOU MAY OPEN ON
THE MEASURE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER HAD
MEMBERS.
SINCE NINETEEN FIFTY NINE THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY OF ISRAEL HAS
STOOD IN SILENCE FOR TWO MINUTES
HE TAPED IT EACH APRIL TO
REMEMBER AND COMMEMORATE THOSE
WHO LOST THEIR LIVES DURING THE
HOLOCAUST.
THIS DAY IN HEBREW IS KNOWN AS
YOM HASHOAH.
TODAY WE MARK THE ANNIVERSARY OF
THE WARSAW GHETTO UPRISING.
IN APRIL AND MAY OF NINETEEN
FORTY THREE.
THE JEWISH COMMUNITY IN THE
WARSAW GHETTO LED AN ARMED
REVOLT AFTER RUMORS THAT THE
GERMANS WOULD DEPORT THE
REMAINING GET WHAT HAPPENS TO
THE TREBLINKA KILLING CENTER.
AS GERMAN AND POLICE UNITS
ENTERED THE GHETTO MEMBERS OF
THE JEWISH FIGHTING ORGANIZATION
AND OTHER JEWISH GROUPS ATTACKED
GERMAN TANKS.
IT TOOK GERMAN FORCES NEARLY A
MONTH BEFORE THEY WERE ABLE TO
COMPLETELY PACIFY THE GHETTO.
SUPPORT VIRTUALLY ALL OF THE
REMAINING INHABITANTS.
THIS ROOM OF THIS HORRIFIC
MOMENT IN HISTORY IS DEEPLY
PERSONAL TO ME.
BECAUSE MY GRANDFATHER ROBERT
ALTMAN WAS BROUGHT TO THIS
COUNTRY BY HIS PARENTS IN
NINETEEN OH EIGHT.
THE REMAINING FAMILY.
REMAINED IN WARSAW GERMANY.
AND I REMEMBER SEEING FOR THE
FIRST TIME
A COPY OF MY FAMILY TREE ON BOTH
MY GRANDMOTHER AND MY
GRANDFATHER SIDE MY
GRANDMOTHER'S FAMILY ALSO CAME
TO THIS COUNTRY AROUND NINETEEN
TEN. TO ESCAPE THE HORRIBLE CHO
PROGRAMS. THAT WERE TERRORIZING
JEWISH COMMUNITIES ACROSS
EASTERN EUROPE.
I'M WHAT'S STRIKING ABOUT THE
FAMILY TREE IS THAT MY
GRANDMOTHER'S FAMILY IS HERE MY
GRANDFATHER'S FAMILY IS ON A
DIFFERENT TREE. AND THERE WERE
DOZENS OF OTHER COUSINS SISTERS
UNCLES AND AUNTS.
OUR FAMILY TREE CONTINUES TO
MYSELF AND TO MY DAUGHTER.
ALL OF THOSE OTHER FAMILY TREES
THAT WARRANT MY GRANDFATHER
SPENT FAMILY MY GRANDMOTHER'S
FAMILY. THEY ALL ENDED.
RIGHT AT THE END OF NINETEEN
THIRTY.
AND I CAN ONLY IMAGINE THAT MY
GRANDFATHER'S FAMILY WHO WAS IN
WARSAW.
PROBABLY PERISHED IN THE WARSAW
GHETTO.
ALL OF THOSE LEGACIES.
ALL OF THOSE POTENTIAL.
AYERS.
ALL THOSE MEMORIES
OF WHAT THAT FAMILY THOSE
FAMILIES WENT THROUGH WERE ALL
ERASED ALL RACE BY THE GERMANS.
YAMAHA SHOW UP THE HOLOCAUST
REMEMBRANCE DAY. REMINDS THE
WORLD TO NEVER FORGET.
BUT WE ARE FORGETTING.
AND WORSE.
RIGHT NOW WITNESSING CONCERTED
EFFORT TO ERASE HISTORY LET ME
TELL YOU WHY THIS RESOLUTION IS
SO IMPORTANT THIS MOMENT.
THE CONFERENCE ON JEWISH
MATERIAL CLAIMS AGAINST GERMANY
OR THE CLAIMS CONFERENCE.
JUST RELEASED FINDINGS OF A
COMPREHENSIVE SURVEY OF
AMERICANS.
THE SURVEY SHOWS A REMARKABLE
LACK OF UNDERSTANDING OF THE
HOLOCAUST.
ESPECIALLY WITH OUR MILLENNIAL
POPULATION AND THOSE YOUNGER.
THE CLAIMS CONFERENCE SAID THAT
QUOTE THERE ARE CRITICAL GAPS
BOTH IN AWARENESS OF BASICS
FACTS AS WELL AS DETAILED
KNOWLEDGE OF THE HOLOCAUST.
THIS IS IN AMERICAN SOCIETY AND
THEY STRESS THE IMPORTANCE OF
PEACE OF.
STEPPING UP OUR EFFORTS TO
EDUCATE OUR POPULATION AND OUR
STUDENTS IN SCHOOLS.
JUST UNDER A THIRD THIRTY ONE
PERCENT OF THOSE AMERICANS
SURVEYED DO NOT BELIEVE THAT SIX
MILLION JEWS PERISHED DURING THE
HOLOCAUST.
THEY BELIEVE IN SAID THAT THE
DEATH TOLL IS SOMEWHERE UNDER
TWO MILLION.
OR LOWER.
THIS WAS TRUE FOR FORTY ONE
PERCENT OF MILLENNIALS.
ALMOST HALF OF AMERICANS.
COULD NOT NAME A SINGLE
CONCENTRATION CAMP.
ALMOST HALF.
TWO THIRDS SIXTY SIX PERCENT OF
MILLENNIALS WERE UNABLE TO
EXPLAIN OR RECOGNIZED WHAT
AUSCHWITZ WAS THIS IS A WORD
THAT'S BECOME SYNONYMOUS WITH
GENOCIDE. AND YET THEY DIDN'T
KNOW WHAT IT MEANT.
ELEVEN PERCENT OF AMERICANS SAID
THAT IT'S ACCEPTABLE TO HOLD NEO
* VIEWS.
AS WE ALL KNOW. LAST YEAR OUR
OWN PRESIDENT.
REFUSED TO CONDEMN A NEO*
MARCH THAT LEAD TO DEATH IN THIS
COUNTRY AND EVEN SAID THAT SOME
OF THE PARTICIPANTS WERE GOOD
PEOPLE.
WHAT'S WORSE IS THE NUMBER OF A
PROMINENT AMERICAN POLITICIANS
AND THOUGHT LEADERS TO REFUSE TO
STAND UP. AND PUBLICLY CONDEMNED
THE PRESIDENT'S STATEMENT.
AT THE SAME TIME AS AMERICANS
ARE FORGETTING ABOUT THE
HOLOCAUST
THE FEBRUARY REPORT FROM THE
SOUTHERN POVERTY LAW CENTER SHOW
THAT THE NUMBER OF HATE GROUPS
IN THE UNITED STATES. HAS
INCREASED BY TWENTY PERCENT IN
THE PAST THREE YEARS.
THE NUMBER OF NEO* GROUPS
HAS INCREASED FROM NINETY NINE
AND TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE AND TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
MEMBERS MANY OF THOSE GROUPS ARE
HEADQUARTERED RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE EVEN SEE THE UGLY FACE OF
ANTI SEMITISM SHOWN PUBLICLY ON
OUR COLLEGE CAMPUSES IN
CALIFORNIA.
HOW MANY AMERICANS THINK THAT
HITLER ROSE TO POWER THROUGH
FORCE THAT IT WASN'T OVER THROW
SOME KIND OF MILITARY COUP IN
GERMANY BUT IT WASN'T?
AND THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER.
HITLER CAME TO POWER THROUGH A
DEMOCRATIC ELECTION.
IN A COUNTRY THAT WAS ONE OF THE
MOST EDUCATED AND AT THE TIME
SOCIALLY PROGRESSIVE NATIONS ON
EARTH.
HE DIDN'T COME TO POWER ON A
PLATFORM OF MASS MURDER NO.
HE VERY INSIDIOUSLY
BEGAN TO A ROAD THE CIVIL
LIBERTIES IN GERMANY.
TURN THE POPULATION AGAINST ONE
ANOTHER BY MARGINALIZING
MINORITY POPULATIONS.
TO WILL ALLOW THOSE RATES TO BE
ERODED OVER TIME.
IT WAS HIS POPULIST VIEWS.
AND THAT STRATEGY OF
MARGINALIZING CITIZENS.
AND TURNING CITIZENS AGAINST ONE
ANOTHER AND AGAINST THEIR
NEIGHBORS THAT LED TO THE
HOLOCAUST.
COLLEAGUES
WE MUST STAND AGAINST THESE
KINDS OF TACTICS WHEN WE SEE
THEM IN OUR MYTHS.
WHEN WE HAVE A CURRENT FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT DE THAT. THAT.
HOLD ON TO POWER AND TRIES TO
GAIN POWER BY MARGINALIZING
MEMBERS OF OUR OWN SOCIETY.
BECAUSE OF THEIR RELIGION.
SIX A DENIED BASIC HUMAN RIGHTS
BASED ON PEOPLE'S GENDER THEIR
SEXUAL ORIENTATION. THEIR RACE
THEIR RELIGION.
TO DEPORT OUR RESIDENTS IN THE
DEAD OF NIGHT TO SEPARATE
FAMILIES FROM THEIR CHILDREN.
WE MUST STAND OUT AGAINST THAT.
CURRENTLY IN POLAND THE LAW WAS
PASSED JUST RECENTLY.
THAT MADE IT A CRIMINAL OFFENSE
TO IMPLY THAT THE POLISH
GOVERNMENT OR EVEN POLISH
CITIZENS WERE IN ANY WAY
COMPLICIT. IN THE HOLOCAUST.
THANKFULLY THE STRONG SURVIVORS
AND IN POLAND HAVE SAID THAT
THEY WILL NOT BE SILENCED THEY
WILL NOT BE AFRAID TO SPEAK THE
TRUTH AND WE HAVE TO STAND IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THEM.
STAND UP AGAINST THAT KIND OF
ERASURE OF HISTORY.
I URGE.
WELL I WANT FIRST OF ALL OF
KNOWLEDGE THE SURVIVORS INERMIS
TODAY.
I THINK THEM FOR STANDING STRONG
FOR BEING HERE TO BEAR WITNESS
TO THAT HISTORY.
WE MUST ALL PLEDGE TO STAND
STRONG AGAINST HATRED
INTOLERANCE AND ANTI SEMITISM
AND THE ERASURE OF HISTORY.
I URGE ALL OF YOU.
A COOPER THIS RESOLUTION I WOULD
ASK FOR THE COURT FIRST ROLE TO
BE OPEN FOR COAUTHORS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MEMBERS MISTER
SPEAKER.
THANK YOU S. FREEMAN.
MR LEVIN MISTER LEVINE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FROM MISTER CALDERON
STATS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I JOIN MY COLLEAGUE FROM
GLENDALE IN SUPPORT OF ACR TWO
OH SEVEN. IT IS WITH MY WHOLE
HEART THAT I EXTEND MY GRATITUDE
TO YOU. FOR WELCOMING SURVIVORS
OF THE SHOAH UNDER THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR TODAY.
AS WE REMEMBER THE SIX MILLION
JEWS WERE MURDERED BY THE*
AND THE HOLOCAUST IS ALARMING TO
KNOW. THAT INSTANCES OF ANTI
SEMITISM THE UNITED STATES ROSE
FIFTY SEVEN PERCENT.
LAST YEAR.
PERHAPS THAT SHOULDN'T BE
SURPRISING IN A TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WEAR WHITE
SUPREMACISTS BRAZENLY CHANTED.
CHOOSE WILL NOT REPLACE US IN
CHARLOTTESVILLE VIRGINIA IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
WE REMEMBER THE PAST
SO WE DON'T REPEAT IT.
ALARMINGLY. AS MY COLLEAGUE
NOTED A RECENT POLL OF WHAT
MILLENNIAL SHOWED THAT TWO
THIRDS DIDNOT KNOW. WHAT
AUSCHWITZ'S?
SO LET ME TELL YOU.
SO WE DON'T REPEAT IT.
AFTER JEWS WERE STRIPPED OF
THEIR CITIZENSHIP.
IN CIVIL RIGHTS BY THE*.
THEY WERE FORCIBLY MOVED INTO
GHETTOS.
THEN THEY WERE FORCED INTO
CATTLE CARS.
AND DELIVER TO CONCENTRATION AND
DEATH CAMPS LIKE AUSCHWITZ.
WHERE THEIR CLOTHING AND
IDENTITIES WERE STRIPPED AWAY?
REPLACED BY NUMBERS TATTOO TO
THEIR ARMS.
CHOOSE OR WORKED TO DEATH.
STARVED TO DEATH.
MARCH DID THAT.
AND FINALLY GASSED TO DEATH.
ULTIMATELY.
SIX MILLION JEWS.
AND FIVE MILLION EQUALLY
INNOCENT LIVES.
WERE MURDERED BY THE*.
AND HOW THEIR FLASH BURNED FROM
THEIR BONES TO ASHES IN PURSUIT
OF ADOLF HITLER'S.
FINAL SOLUTION.
TO KILL ALL THE JEWS OF EUROPE.
THAT'S WHAT OFFICES.
AND THAT WAS JUST ONE OF SIX
DEATH CAMPS.
AMONG DOZENS OF CONCENTRATION
CAMPS.
TODAY WE ARE HONORED TO BE IN
THE PRESENCE OF SURVIVORS OF THE
HOLOCAUST.
WE'RE ALSO JOINED BY THEIR
DESCENDANTS.
AND LIBERATORS WHO FREE EUROPE
FROM HITLER AND THE*.
I CANNOT THINK OUR HONOREES
ENOUGH FOR BEING HERE THANK YOU.
YOUR TRUE HEROES REMIND US THAT
HOPE AND PERSEVERANCE CAN
SURVIVE IN A WORLD.
FILLED WITH DARKNESS.
WE MUST REMEMBER.
ELLIE WAS ALSO SAID TO FORGET
THE DEAD WOULD BE A CAN.
TO KILLING THEM A SECOND TIME.
MEMBERS THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
REMEMBERING THE HOLOCAUST TODAY.
SWIMMING NEVER REPEAT IT PLEASE
JOIN ME IN VOTING AYE ON ACR TO
A SEVEN.
THANK YOU MITCHELL BEING.
MR MEDINA.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LATINO LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS.
A PORT OF ACR TWO OH SEVEN.
THROUGHOUT HISTORY THE JEWISH
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN SUBJUGATED TO
UNWARRANTED PERSECUTION.
IT IS FOR THIS REASON THAT EVERY
YEAR IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY. HONORS THOSE WHO
EXPERIENCE
UNIMAGINABLE EVIL.
SPIKE THE RISE IN ANTI SEMITISM
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD.
THERE WERE THOSE WHO WERE BRAVE
ENOUGH TO SPEAK OUT AGAINST
HITLER'S REDEEM.
BET THOUGH BUSCA SIDE OF OUR A
MEXICAN DIPLOMAT.
RESCUED THE LIVES OF THOUSANDS
OF JEWS BY ISSUING THEM VISAS TO
MEXICO.
AS WE REMEMBER THE ATROCITIES OF
THE HOLOCAUST WE MISS ALSO VOWED
TO REJECT. ALL FORMS OF HATE AND
BIGOTRY.
TO PREVENT THE PERSECUTION
OF ALL PEOPLE IN THE FUTURE.
I URGE AND I VOTE ON ACR TWO OH
SEVEN.
THANK YOU MR MEDINA MISTER
NAZARIAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASIAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF ACR TO SEVEN FOUR
HOLOCAUST REMEMBRANCE DAY.
THANK YOU TO THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN
FROM GLENDALE AND THE
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS.
FOR THE LEADERSHIP AND
RECOGNIZING THIS DAY. AS WE ALL
REMEMBER AND PAY OUR RESPECTS TO
THE MILLIONS OF INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES WHO LOST THEIR LIVES
UNDER* GERMANY'S REIGN OF
TERROR.
WE MUST NOT FORGET THE HARD
THESE VICTIMS FACED MORE THAN
SEVENTY YEARS AGO.
AND JUST AS IMPORTANTLY WE MUST
NOT FORGET THE FACTORS THAT LED
TO THIS ATROCITY.
WHEN THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE WAS
MET WITH SILENCE.
ADOLPH HITLER IN PERSUADING HIS
ARMY COMMANDERS THAT THE
MERCILESS PERSECUTION AND
KILLING OF JEWS AND OTHERS.
WOULD BRING NO RETRIBUTION
DECLARED.
WHO AFTER ALL SPEAKS TODAY OF
THE ANNIHILATION OF THE
ARMENIANS?
LESS THAN FOR DECADES AFTER THE
HOLOCAUST ANOTHER GENOCIDE
OCCURRED.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE.
A REGIME LED BY POL POT EXECUTED
NEARLY A QUARTER OF CAMBODIA'S
POPULATION.
AS YOU REFLECT ON THESE
FRIGHTENING TIMES.
WE MUST REMEMBER TO STAND WITH
ONE ANOTHER AND SPEAK OUT TO
ENSURE THAT THESE ACTS.
OF VIOLENCE ON INDIVIDUALS OVER
THEIR BACKGROUNDS THEIR
CULTURES.
RELIGIONS EVEN TRIBES.
WILL NOT OCCUR AGAIN.
WE OWE IT TO OUR COMMUNITIES AND
FUTURE GENERATIONS TO REMEMBER
OUR PAST.
AND LEARN IN ORDER TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH RESPECT AND
COMPASSION FOR ALL PEOPLE.
I STRONGLY URGE AN AYE VOTE FOR
ACR TOOL SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN MISTER
BERMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE ON SUPPORT IN
SUPPORT OF ACR TO A SEVEN. LIKE
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR GLENDALE
FOR HER AUTHORSHIP IN LEADERSHIP
HERE.
I'M SPEAKING TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF ACR TWO OH
SEVEN.
TODAY'S THE DAY THAT WE REMEMBER
THE PEOPLE THAT LOST THEIR LIVES
DURING THE HOLOCAUST.
WE MOURN THE LIVES OF THE SIX
MILLION JEWS IN FIVE MILLION
OTHERS.
WHO ALSO LOST THEIR LIVES?
AND I'M DEEPLY APPRECIATIVE
TODAY FOR US TO HAVE SURVIVORS
AND FAMILY MEMBERS WHO ARE IN
THE CHAMBER WHO'VE MADE THEIR
VOICES HEARD. WHO'D BEEN PART OF
THE SACRIFICES STRUGGLE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE NEVER EVER FORGET.
LIKE
THE SIX MILLION JEWISH PEOPLE
AFRICAN AMERICANS AND OTHERS IN
* GERMANY.
FACE TREATMENT THAT INCLUDE A
PERSECUTION.
STERILIZATION MEDICAL
EXPERIMENTATION ILLEGAL CAR
SERRATION AND EVEN MURDER.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE TAKE
TIME TO REFLECT ON THE HOLOCAUST
AS A REMINDER OF THE RESULTS OF
UNCHECKED HATE. AND
DISCRIMINATION
WE MUST NEVER FORGET.
YOU HEARD FROM MY COLLEAGUES OF
REPORTS THAT TALKED ABOUT THOSE
WHO HAVE NO UNDERSTANDING OR
LIMITED AWARENESS OF THE
HOLOCAUST.
OF ITS TRUTHFULNESS OF THE
IMPACT THAT IT HAS HAD ON OUR
WORLD.
YOU HEARD FROM MY COLLEAGUES
THAT WE HAVE SEEN THE RISE AGAIN
OF NEO* BEHAVIOR EVEN IN
THIS COUNTRY AND THAT IT WAS
SANCTIONED. BY OUR PRESIDENT AND
I'M DEEPLY HONORED THAT OUR
COLLEAGUE SOFT. TO REBUKE OUR
PRESIDENT FOR HIS LEGITIMIZATION
OF THOSE WHO WOULD PROSPER HATE
FROM THE NEO*.
FAME NOBEL PRIZE AUTHOR IN
HOLOCAUST SURVIVOR.
NOW THE WE SO ONCE SAID WITHOUT
MEMORY THERE IS NO CULTURE
WITHOUT MEMORY THERE WOULD BE NO
CIVILIZATION. NO SOCIETY NO
FUTURE.
THIS RESOLUTION AND OTHER ACTS
OF REMEMBRANCE ARE CRITICAL.
THAT WE. AND IMPORTANT NOW MORE
THAN EVER THAT WE NEVER FORGET.
I URGE AN AYE VOTE FOR ACR TO
OWES THEM.
THANK YOU MISTER THURMAN
RESENTMENT.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF ACR TWO OH
SEVEN AND THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM GLENDALE FOR HER. POWERFUL
REMARKS.
WOMEN WERE SUBJECT TO THEM SOME
OF THE MOST IN HUMANE TREATMENT
DURING THE* REGIME.
MOTHERS WERE SEPARATE FROM THEIR
CHILDREN.
CHILDREN'S RIPPED FROM THEIR
BREAST
PREGNANT WOMEN OFTEN FORCE IN
THE GAS CHAMBER FIRST AS THEY
WERE DEEMED INCAPABLE OF
WORKING.
PERHAPS MOST TRAGICALLY WHERE
THE RAPES
THE TORTURES AND THE
EXPERIMENTATION ON JEWISH AND
GYPSY WOMEN BY THE*.
THE WOMAN WHO SURVIVED THESE
HORRIFIC EVENTS WERE FOREVER
SCARRED.
SOME OF THEM WHO ARE HERE TODAY
WITH US THROW THEIR DESCENDANTS
ARE HERE WITH US WHO HAVE LIVED
WITH THE STORIES. OF THOSE
TRAGEDIES.
DESPITE THOSE* SO MEMBERS.
WE'RE WERE TO THE HOLOCAUST THEY
ALSO PROVIDE US WITH HOPE.
IN WHICH WOMEN WERE THE HEROES.
WOMEN LIKE ME THE CAMPER.
WHO IS A LEADER IN THE
RESISTANCE IN THE LITHUANIAN
GHETTO AND WHEN THE FIRST WOMEN
TO PARTICIPATE IN COORDINATING
THE EXPLOSION? OF A* TRAIN.
WOMEN LIKE NOR IN NOT CON THE
FIRST FEMALE OPERATOR TO BE SENT
FROM BRITAIN TO ASSIST THE
FRENCH RESISTANCE.
NANCY WAKE IN NEW ZEELAND NATIVE
WHO BECAME AN UNDERGROUND
CAREER.
RUTH GRUBER AN AMERICAN
JOURNALIST TO PUT PHOTOGRAPHERS
NOT ONLY THOSE IN INTERVIEWED IN
THE CAMP.
THE BRINGING THEIR STORIES TO
LIFE.
AND RISKING HER LIFE TO RESCUE
ONE THOUSAND JEWISH REFUGEE AND
WOUNDED AMERICAN SOLDIERS.
LIKE LINDA STERN WHO HAS
MEMORISED MEMORIZE WHAT MANY OF
THESE PEOPLE WE MUST FIND WAYS.
CREATIVE AND UNIQUE.
HONOR THE STRONG WOMEN WHO
STORIES HAVE FADED SOMETIMES
INTO THE FABRIC OF THE MALE
DOMINATED HISTORY.
KEEP THEIR MEMORY ALIVE.
WE REMEMBER ALL THOSE WHOSE
LIVES WERE UNJUSTLY LOST
WE REMEMBER THE HATE THAT
SPURRED THE LOSS OF THOSE LIVES
AND THAT TRAGEDY.
BUT WE WILL FOR EVER REMEMBER
THE WOMEN AND OTHERS WHO
EMBODIED STRENGTH.
PERSEVERANCE AND LEADERSHIP IN
THE FACE OF OPPRESSION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN.
MISTER GALLAGHER.
THE USER SPEAKER MEMBERS I ALSO
RISE IN SOLIDARITY WITH MY
COLLEAGUES AND WITH THE
SURVIVORS AND DESCENDANTS OF
SURVIVORS WHO ARE HERE TODAY.
.
AS REMEMBER THIS TERRIBLE
ATROCITY.
THAT TOOK PLACE IN WE IN WE CALL
OUT WE STATE THE FACTS OF WHAT
HAPPENED IN THE HOLOCAUST.
AND AS PAINFUL.
AS THAT IS FOR ESPECIALLY FOR
THOSE WHO LIVED.
THROUGH IT WE MUST REMEMBER.
IN I JOIN THE REMARKS OF MY
COLLEAGUES THAT.
.
THIS SURVEY THAT SHOWED.
HOW MANY OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE DO
NOT KNOW ABOUT THIS HISTORY DO
NOT KNOW THE FACTS?
IT SHOULD RESOLVE IN US THAT WE
NEED TO IMPROVE.
THE TEACHING OF HISTORY IN OUR
SCHOOLS.
OUR BECAUSE MYSELF AND.
IN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL READING THE
DIARY OF ANNE FRANK.
AND HOW THAT BECAME REAL FOR ME
BECAME REAL FOR ME IN READING.
THAT STORY THE HISTORY BECAME
REAL HISTORY NEEDS TO BECOME
REAL AGAIN THAT PEOPLE REMEMBER
IT. NOT JUST REMEMBER IT BUT
THEN THEY BECOME RESOLVE THAT IT
WOULD NEVER HAPPEN AGAIN.
AND I ALSO JOIN THE CALLS THAT
WE NEED TO CONTINUE.
TO CALL OUT ANTI SEMITISM AND
HATRED AND BIGOTRY WHEREVER IT
REARS ITS HEAD.
BOTH HERE AT HOME AND ABROAD.
IT WILL NEED TO CALL IT OUT IN
THE MIDDLE EAST.
WHERE THERE ARE STILL?
SOVEREIGN STATES WHO SAY THAT
ISRAEL DOES NOT HAVE A RIGHT TO
EXIST WE NEED TO CALL THEM OUT
AND WE NEED TO STAND RESOLUTE
AGAINST THEM.
WHEN IT HAPPENS IN THE UN.
AND RESOLUTIONS ARE PASSED
AGAINST ISRAEL.
AND IT IS MODE AND AND WHAT WE
CALL AND WE SAY THAT IS
MOTIVATED BY ANTI SEMITISM IT
IS.
WE NEED TO CALL IT OUT.
AND SO I JOIN MY COLLEAGUES WE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO DO THAT
CONTINUE TO SPEAK TRUTH.
HERE AT HOME.
AND ABROAD.
AND I THANK YOU FOR BRINGING FOR
THIS RESOLUTION.
I THANK YOU FOR THOSE WHO ARE
JOINING AS WE REMEMBER TODAY.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER MISS
QUIRK SILVA.
THANK YOU MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
AS AN EDUCATOR.
I'VE TAUGHT IN THE CLASS FOR
MORE THAN THIRTY YEARS AND I TOO
HAVE SEEN WHERE THERE WAS MUCH
EMPHASIS ON THIS HISTORY AND
OVER THE YEARS A LITTLE BY
LITTLE LESS AND LESS IS TAUGHT.
UP WHEN I WAS HERE IN TWENTY
TWELVE AND TWENTY THIRTEEN I WAS
PROUD TO BRING UP THE WIFE OF
LEON LEYSIN. AND LEON LACE AND
WAS THE YOUNGEST MEMBER ON
SCHINDLER'S LIST WHO LIVES IN MY
CITY OF FULLER TEN. HE WROTE A
BOOK THAT WE WERE ABLE TO GIVE
TO THE MEMBERS AT THAT TIME BOY
ON THE WOODEN BOX.
AND BOY ON THE WOODEN BOXES THE
STORY OF LEON LEYSIN IS FAMILY
HIS BROTHERS AND HIS SISTER AND
HIS MOTHER ALL WHO PASSED OTHER
THAN HIM. AND HIS PARENTS.
AND AS HE CAME HERE TO AMERICA
AFTER.
LIVING THAT HORROR HE CAME AND
SETTLED IN HUNTINGTON PARK WHERE
HE THEN BE KIND CAME AND METAL
SHOP TEACHER.
AND THERE ARE MANY STORIES OF
HORROR AND WITH LEON YOU WOULD
NEVER HAVE KNOWN WHAT HAPPENED
BECAUSE HE DIDN'T SPEAK ABOUT
IT.
HE DIDN'T SPEAK ABOUT IT INTEL.
SCHINDLER'S LIST CAME OUT
AND TELL THE MOVIE CAME OUT I
HAD ALREADY KNOWN IN TWENTY
YEARS AND TO HEAR HIS STORY
SOMEBODY WHO HAD DINNER AT IS
HOME. TO SEE A MAN THAT WENT
THROUGH SO MUCH AND THAT CAME
BACK AND JUST LOVE THOSE
STUDENTS IN LOS ANGELES BUT HE
MET HIS WIFE OUT THERE AND ONE
OF THE STORIES THAT I LOVE SO
MUCH BECAUSE SHE CAME TO MY
CLASSROOM. TO TALK TO OVER A
HUNDRED STUDENTS IN FULLERTON
JUST TWO YEARS AGO WAS THAT WHEN
SHE MET HIM AS A YOUNG TEACHER
HERSELF SHE WENT INTO HIS METAL
SHOP. AND HE WAS SHOWING THE
STUDENTS HOW TO DO VARIOUS METAL
SHOP AND LATER ON HE MADE HER A
TROWEL. AND EVEN MY STUDENTS
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT A TRIAL WAS BUT
SHE BROUGHT THAT TRAVEL TO THE
CLASS AND SAID THAT WAS A GIFT
HE GAVE HER. AND THAT THE KIDS
OF ALMOST CRIED IN THIS WAS JUST
TWO YEARS AGO SO WE CONTINUE
YOUR LEGACY WHAT YOU WENT
THROUGH BY TELLING THE STORIES
IN KEEPING THOSE MEMORIES ALIVE
SO KEEP TELLING YOUR STORIES.
AND THANK YOU SURVIVORS ICE IN
HERE TO SUPPORT ACR TWO OH
SEVEN.
THINKING IS QUIRK SILVA.
IF ANY OTHER QUESTION TO BE ON
THE SIDE OF.
SEEN NONE IN HEARING NONE
MISTREATMENT YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU I'D LIKE TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR ADDING THEIR
VOICES
I ONCE AGAIN WANT TO THANK ALL
OF OUR VERY SPECIAL VERY HONORED
VERY PRECIOUS GAS THAT ARE HERE
TODAY. WITHOUT I WOULD ASK FOR
THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR
COAUTHORS.
THE FIRST ROLL CALL WILL BE FOR
COOPER IS ON EACH YEAR TO A
SEVEN THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
THIS IS FOR COOPERS.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE.
SEVENTY THREE CO AUTHORS.
OUR FINAL CALL IS ON THE BILL WE
CAN TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THIS
ITEM. ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY
AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
TO MARK HOLOCAUST MEMORIAL DAY
THE MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY HAVE
INVITED SURVIVORS LIBERATORS AND
FAMILY MEMBERS TO JOIN US TODAY.
WE'VE EXTENDED TO THEM THE
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
AS YOUR NAME IS RED PLEASE STAND
AT YOUR SEAT IF YOU'RE ABLE OR
WAY IF IF YOU CAN'T.
MEMBERS AND GUESTS PLEASE HOLD
YOUR APPLAUSE
AFTER ALL OF THE GAS.
HAVE BEEN INTRODUCED WE WILL
SALUTE OUR GAS
THE CLERK WILL READ.
AT THE DESK ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR CURRY IS HENRY BECAUSE
SKI A SURVIVOR.
IN WE WAS BORN IN KAZAKHSTAN
FOLLOWING WORLD WAR TWO HE ALSO
LIVED IN A DISPLACED PERSONS
CAMP OF ARIA AND IN NINETEEN
FORTY NINE. AGE FOUR HE ARRIVED
IN THE UNITED STATES WITH HIS
PARENTS AND BROTHER.
AT THE DESK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAKER IS IT SICK ALONG THE SON
OF HENRY TREASURE A SURVIVOR.
HE WAS BORN IN POLAND IN
NINETEEN TWENTY FOUR AND SURVIVE
THE PLANTS NOW IN MY HOUSE IN
CONCENTRATION CAMPS BECAUSE OF
HIS TAILORING SKILLS. AND
BEAUTIFUL SINGING VOICE.
AT THE DESK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN IS JUDITH ROBBIE IS
SURVIVOR.
MISS ROBBIE WAS BORN IN HUNGARY
AND DURING THE HOLOCAUST WAS
HIDDEN BY A NON JEWISH FAMILY.
SHE VOLUNTEER SO TIME TO ENSURE
FUTURE GENERATIONS NEVER FORGET.
AT THE DESK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PLUMAS DR HENRY H. OSTER A
SURVIVOR.
HE WAS BORN IN NINETEEN EIGHTEEN
IN COLOGNE GERMANY HE IS A
SURVIVOR OF AUSCHWITZ BIRKENAU
DEATH CAMP AND OFFERED THE BOOK
TITLED THE KINDNESS OF THE
HANGED MAN.
IT WAS A SUBJECT OF A DOCTORATE
DOCUMENTARY FILM ONE IN THIRTY.
AT THE DESK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA IS SABRINA ARCO A CHILD OF
A SURVIVOR.
SABRINA COHEN WAS MORE AND MORE
MARBURG GERMANY IN A DISPLACED
PERSONS CAMP TO PARENTS WHO HAVE
SURVIVED THE HOLOCAUST.
SABRINA WAS RAISED IN NEW YORK
AND WENT ON TO EARN A PHD IN
EDUCATION FROM STANFORD.
AT THE DESK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SAVANT TENSES MERRY EYES AND
KRAMER A CHILD OF SURVIVORS.
SHE IS OUR TO COMMEMORATE THE
LIVES OF HER PARENTS HARRY IN
ILL HILDA EYES IN BOTH HOLOCAUST
SURVIVORS WHO EXEMPLIFY THE
MEETING YOUR PERSEVERANCE. AND
THE AMERICAN DREAM.
AT THE DESK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHAO'S JUDY STROBEL A SURVIVOR.
MISERABLE SURVIVED THE STALINIST
PURGES AND THE HOLOCAUST.
AN ARTIST SHE ESCAPES HER DARK
MEMORIES INTO INTO STUNNING
TAPESTRIES THAT THE PICK THE
HORSE SHE SURVIVED AS A GIRL.
AT THE DESK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DAVID CHIU WAS A WEEK OLD FOR A
GRANDCHILD OF SURVIVORS.
MS NO WE GOLDFARB IS THE FOUNDER
OF THREE G. ESSE A PROGRAM OF
THE JEWISH FAMILY AND CHILDREN'S
SERVICES HOLOCAUST CENTER WHICH
CONNECTS GRANDCHILDREN. OF
HOLOCAUST SURVIVORS
SHE LIVES IN SAN FRANCISCO'S NOE
VALLEY.
AFTER DESK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KANSEN SURE BENJAMIN GAGE AND
GEORGE GAUGE THE BROTHERS OF
RUTH GAUGE PEROT A SECOND
GENERATION SURVIVOR. THEY ARE
THE CHILDREN OF HENRY AND
FRANCIS GAGE.
AT THE DESK OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOLEY IS ADAM GREENSPAN A
SURVIVOR.
ADAM GREENSPAN WAS FOUR YEARS
OLD WHEN BOMB SPILLING HIS
HOMETOWN OF RUDNICK POLAND IN
NINETEEN THIRTY NINE. IT WASN'T
UNTIL NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN
BEFORE HE WAS ABLE TO EMIGRATE
TO AMERICA AND BECAME A
SUCCESSFUL RADIOLOGISTS.
AT THE DESK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EGGMAN IS FREE TO LIVING IN
START WHITE A CHILD OF A
SURVIVOR. HER FATHER DR ROBERT
LILLIAN STEIN LEFT GERMANY AT
AGE EIGHT WITH HIS PARENTS AND
BROTHER MANFRED.
IT WAS STOP MOPING* WORN
ROBERTS POSITION FATHER TO FLEE
OR BE ARRESTED.
AFTER DESK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN AS HERBERT MIRRORS A
SURVIVOR.
ESCAPING THE U. S. ON
KRISTALLNACHT HERBERT NEAR ISN'T
LISTED IN THE U. S. ARMY WHERE
HE TRANSLATED MILITARY DOCUMENTS
INCLUDING MILITARY ORDER SIGNED
BY ADOLF HITLER.
AT THE DESK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA IS A FORMER
STANDING A CHILD OF A SURVIVOR.
MR THINKS FAMILY WAS DESTROYED
AND DISPLACED BY THE* IN
GERMANY WERE SOME ESCAPED BUT
UNFORTUNATELY OTHERS WERE
KILLED.
AT THE DESK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA HASBRO'S SCHINDLER A
SURVIVOR.
ROSHAN WAS FOURTEEN WHEN SHE WAS
INTERNET THE* DEATH CAMP
AUSCHWITZ BIRKENAU.
SHEILA TWO OLDER SISTERS WERE
THE ONLY FAMILY MEMBERS TO
SURVIVE.
AT THE DESK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON ASSEMBLY ARMCO STORY A
SURVIVOR.
HE WAS BORN IN NINETEEN THIRTY
NINE IN ODESSA UKRAINE AND
SURVIVE THREE YEARS OF
CAPTIVITY.
SADDAM MIGHT GALLAGHER
CONCENTRATION CAMP.
AT THE DESK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN IS IS A BILL TO RESET
HUMOR A SURVIVOR.
HE WAS BORN IN MARCH NINETEEN
THIRTY NINE IN SORT CAL POLAND.
WHAT'S YOUR LIVES IN CLAREMONT
AND IS JOINED TODAY BY HER
DAUGHTER MICHELLE HUMOR.
AT THE DESK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KILEY IS STARING GUTMANN A CHILD
OF SURVIVORS.
S. FATHER JOE GROUPEMENT SPENT
THE WAR AND HOW GARY GO. HE HAS
PARENTS AND EIGHT SIBLINGS WERE
ALL SURVIVORS.
AT THE DESK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEY A SUSAN QUORUM BLITZ
FROM.
THIS WRONG WAS THE DAUGHTER OF
TO HOLD ACROSS OF WIRES
AS A TEACHER FOR OVER FIFTEEN
YEARS SHE SEEKS TO EDUCATE YOU.
ON THE HOLOCAUST.
AFTER DESK OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEVINE IS ON TRIGGERED BY A
SURVIVOR.
FROM BUDAPEST HUNGARY TO SAN
RAFAEL CALIFORNIA ENTREGA BODY
SURVIVED THE HOLOCAUST TO BUILD
A FAMILY AND A SUCCESSFUL CAREER
DESPITELIVING TOO MUCH
UNCERTAINTY. DANGER AND SADNESS.
AT THE DESK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW WAS IDA GUREVICH A SURVIVOR.
I DON'T IS A HOLOCAUST SURVIVOR
BORN IN ROMANIA.
AFTER THE WAR SHE MOVED TO
RUSSIA WHERE SHE LIVED FOR OVER
FIFTY YEARS SHE NOW LIVES IN SAN
JOSE.
AT THE DESK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHIS IS MIRIAM EATERY FAIRS A
SURVIVOR.
HER CHILDHOOD WAS STOLEN FOR
EVER WHEN THE* ENTERED PORT
AU FRANCE DURING WORLD WAR TWO.%
EVERY DAY BECAME A STRUGGLE TO
STAY ALIVE MIRIAM AND HER FAMILY
SURVIVED A TERRIFYING AND
PERSUASIVE VENT.
AT THE DESK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY IS MARIA FRIEDMAN A
SURVIVOR.
HE WAS BORN IN PROBABLY POLAND
IN NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT.
MARIA AND SEVERAL FAMILY MEMBERS
SURVIVE MULTIPLE POLISH GHETTOS
AND CONCENTRATION CAMPS TO
BECOME A DELIGHTFULLY FEISTY
SHARP AND INDEPENDENT WOMAN.
AT THE DESK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA IS YOLANDA GRIN ARE A
CHILD OF SURVIVORS.
YOU LOUDEST PARENTS URBAN ART
AND RITA GRANADA.
HER MOTHER RISKY BEING SENT TO
AUSCHWITZ BY PLAYING ON A
BICYCLE AND HER FATHER A MEMBER
OF THE DUTCH ARMY SAVED FIFTY
NINE JEWISH CITIZENS.
AB THE DESK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI IS GEORGE MAYOR A
SURVIVOR.
HE WAS BORN IN NINETEEN FORTY IN
RUSSIA OCCUPIED POLAND AND AS A
CHILD WAS SHELTER BY STRANGERS
WHO BECAME LIKE FAMILY THINKS TO
HERSELF SACKS.
AT THE DESK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DOES AREAS AND SIGNET A
SURVIVOR.
HE IS A RESIDENT OF SHERMAN OAKS
WHO SURVIVED THE HOLOCAUST BY
HIDING WITH HER FAMILY IN A
SMALL TOWN AFTER FLEEING ROOM.
AT THE DESK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OBERNOLTE IS ANTHONY COOKER A
LIBERATOR.
MISTER COOPER SERVED IN THE
TWENTIETH ARMORED DIVISION ALSO
KNOWN AS THE LIBERATORS
LIBERATING THE CONCENTRATION
CAMP DACHAU IN GERMANY.
AT THE DESK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK IS LYNN TALIS A SURVIVOR.
TO TELL US WAS BORN IN NINETEEN
FORTY IN ODESSA UKRAINE.
IT'S FAMILY FLED TO RUSSIA
DURING THE WAR AND ULTIMATELY
MIGRATED TO THE UNITED STATES.
AB THE DESK OF SPEAKER RENDON A
CECILIA FILER SHOUT OVER
SURVIVOR.
HER MOTHER HER MOTHER HELEN
FRIEDMAN SURVIVED AUSCHWITZ AND
SLAVE LABOR CAMPS IN POLAND.
UNTIL HER DEATH SHE COMMITTED
HERSELF TO THE REMEMBRANCE OF
THE HOLOCAUST THROUGH EDUCATION.
AT THE DESK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RADIUS IS RABBI HILLEL CLONE A
SURVIVOR.
A NATIVE OF GERMANY RABBI CONE
ESCAPE NAZISM AND CAME TO THE U.
S. IN NINETEEN THIRTY NINE
ADVOCATING FOR THOSE LESS
FORTUNATE HAS BEEN HIS LIFELONG
MISSION.
AT THE DESK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STEINORTH IS DAVID WIENER A
SURVIVOR.
MR RENO SURVIVE MULTIPLE*
LABOR CAMPS BEFORE HE ESCAPED
AND WAS RESCUED BY AMERICAN
TROOPS.
AT THE DESK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TING IS RABBI CALL OFFENDERS A
GRANDDAUGHTER OF A SURVIVOR.
RABBI CALLER FRIEND THIS IS A
CLERGY MEMBER OF CONGREGATION
MANUAL IN SAN FRANCISCO AND THE
GRANDDAUGHTER OF HOLOCAUST
SURVIVORS IRVINE IN PURE FITNESS
OF BUDAPEST.
AT THE DESK OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN HAS BEEN STERN A
SURVIVOR.
AS A WHOLE ACROSS CANCEL BARBER
HE LIT FUELS PUBLIC BATTLES
AGAINST* IN SKOKIE ILLINOIS
IN BERKELEY CALIFORNIA. HIS
STORY IS ONE OF COURAGE KINDNESS
AND HOPE.
THE FOLLOWING GAS WERE UNABLE TO
ATTEND TODAY FROM THE THIRTIETH
DISTRICT REPRESENTED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COST AS MISTER
URBAN DETER A LIBERATOR.
HE SERVED AS A MEDIC IN WORLD
WAR TWO THROUGHOUT EUROPE
TENDING TO SURVIVORS OF THE
DACHAU CONCENTRATION CAMP IN
SOUTHERN GERMANY.
BEING OUR POSTHUMOUSLY BY SOME
REMEMBER CUNNINGHAM FROM THE
THIRTY FIFTH DISTRICT IS ROLANDA
FRENCHIE AHMANSON A LIBERATOR.
MISTER ARM IT'S UNSERVED AND
ALLIED INTELLIGENCE SURVIVED
IMPRISONMENT AT MAUTHAUSEN WAS
AGO ARMORY GREEN BARRETTE IT
BECAME A FIXTURE OF THE POSSIBLE
WAS COMMUNITY.
IN THE SIXTY NINTH DISTRICT
REPRESENTED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
DALY IS HARRY PAT HARPER A
LIBERATOR.
MISTER HOFFA BURTON LISTED IN
THE ARMY AIR CORPS NINETEEN
FORTY TWO AND WAS PROBABLY A. TO
A TRANSPORT SQUADRON HE MET
HOLOCAUST VICTIMS AS THEY WERE
BEING RELEASED FROM ADJOURNMENT
CAMPS.
HE AND HIS CREW OFTEN GAVE UP
HER OWN RATIONS AND CLOTHING
TORTURE VICTIMS WERE TAKEN CARE
WITH HONOR AND DIGNITY.
BEING HONOR POSTHUMOUSLY BY
SIMILAR BILLY MOANED FOR THE
THIRTY SEVENTH DISTRICT AS
BERNARD BERNIE PENNER
A SURVIVOR.
MISTER PENNER IMMIGRATED TO THE
U. S. AS A CHILD.
HIS LIFE WAS SMART THE SAME FATE
AS HIS PARENTS WHO WERE KILLED
ENCAMPMENT NINETEEN FORTY TWO.
FROM A SEVENTY SEVEN TH DISTRICT
REPRESENTED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN AMONG YOU AND ME
CLOSE WAFFEN FOOLS.
BUT OFTEN FULLS OF SURVIVORS
FROM TWO DIFFERENT COUNTRIES
THEIR SHARE THEIR STORIES WITH
THE SHOW UP FOUNDATION AND
PARTICIPATED IN THE MARCH OF THE
LIVING.
FROM THE FORTY SECOND DISTRICT
REPRESENTED BY SIMPLY RIVER
BASINS LINDA BEEN A SURVIVOR.
SHE WAS BORN IN VIENNA AUSTRIA
IMMIGRATED TO THE UNITED STATES
IN NINETEEN FORTY.
SHE CURRENTLY VOLUNTEERS AT THE
TOLERANCE EDUCATION CENTER IN
RANCHO MIRAGE.
FROM THE FORTY NINTH DISTRICT
REPRESENTED BY SOME REMEMBER
RUBIO IS DOCTOR WILLIAM GOOD A
SURVIVOR.
HE WAS BORN IN NINETEEN TWENTY
FOUR AND A BILL TO POLAND.
HE SURVIVED AFTER ESCAPING THREE
EXECUTION ATTEMPTS DURING THE
HOLOCAUST AND NOW WORKS AS A
FAMILY PHYSICIAN.
AND FROM ASSEMBLY FIFTH DISTRICT
REPRESENTED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WALDRON IS BERNARD SULKOWICZ.
A SURVIVOR.
MR SULKOWICZ IS LIVING PROOF
THAT GOOD CAN'T TRIUMPH OVER
EVIL.
HE SURVIVED INSPITE OF THE ODDS
AGAINST THEM IN SPITE OF A WAR
HE ENTERED.
MR SULKOWICZ IS THE DEFINITION
OF COURAGE.
MEMBERS AND GUESTS PLEASE JOIN
ME IN AN AUDITORY SALUTE TO OUR
VERY SPECIAL GUESTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES
.
YOU MAY BE SEATED.
WE ARE JOINED BY SPECIAL GUESTS
WERE IN THE REAR OF THE
WE ARE THE CHAMBER.
I'M ISRAEL PLEASE WELCOME THE
GENERAL.
NORTHWEST
MOBILE XIN.
AND DEPUTY
GENERAL HONORABLE REVIEW BEAR.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO WELCOME ALL
OTHER SPECIAL GUESTS INCLUDING
OUR COLLEAGUES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA SENATE WERE PRESENT
FOR SPECIAL CEREMONY.
AT THIS TIME I INVITE RABBI
KANTOR ROSEN BROWN TO RETURN TO
THE ROSTRUM. AND DELIVER THE
MOURNER'S KADDISH.
I INVITE ASSAULT TO RISE.
AS WE MOURN AND REMEMBER THE SIX
MILLION.
YOU'VE GOT DEL VIET. XIN MAY
RABBI.
BELMONT DE RASK IRRITATE THE ON
LEAST MONTHLY TAE. THE HIGHER
HOMEOWNER VEHEMENT CLONE OF A
HIGH EIGHT THE WHOLE BAY TO
THROW EL BAGA LA VEES MINE
MCCARTY V. MERU I'M MAIN.
YEAH I HASTEN A RABBI I'M OF OUR
OUT LOUD WELL I'M A ON MY.
.
HE PARA SPEECH TO BY THE PA R.
VITRO MOM BEAT NOT SAY. VETO
DIRE VIA THAILAND VETO ALLOWS
SHE MADE A COULD CHABRIER WHO.
LET A LOT MEAN CALLED VERSAILLES
TAVIS YOU'RE OUTTA. TO SPECIFIED
HAVE ENOUGH SEMATA DUMMY RUN
BAILOUT BEING REAL ON MAIN.
YEAH HAY SLAMA RABBI MEANS TO
MAYA. MESS AYE EAM AYE LAY
NOUVELLE CALL YOU SIR I EL THE
MERU.
MAIN.
SAY SHALOM THE ROMA WHO YA SE
SHOW ALONE. UGLY NOUVELLE CALL
YOU SIR I AM THEY'LL CALL YOU
WISH THEY'D TAKE VELVETY MERU ON
MAIN. SEE HANAMI ROSS LE MAY
THEIR MEMORIES ALWAYS BE FOR A
BLESSING.
PLEASE BE SEATED.
WE ENCOURAGE GUESTS TO VIEW
ESPECIALLY EXHIBIT ABOUT THE
VENOM UNDERGROUND IN THE SECOND
FLOOR ROTUNDA OF THE CAPITOL.
ON BEHALF OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
JEWISH CAUCUS WE EXTEND OUR
APPRECIATION TO YOU FOR
ASSISTING US IN OUR EFFORTS TO
HELP.
FUTURE GENERATIONS NEVER FORGET.
THIS CONCLUDES OUR CEREMONY
PLEASE REMAIN SEATED AS WE
CONTINUE SESSION
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A
BRIEF FIVE MINUTE RECESS TO
ALLOW. OUR GUESTS AT TO DEPART
IF THEY WISH THE GAS MAY ALSO
REMAIN ON THE FLOOR IF THEY WISH
FOR THE REMAINDER. OF SESSION
MEMBERS WE WILL RESUME SESSION
SHORTLY.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS ON THE
FLOOR
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
WE WILL RESUME BUSINESS BEFORE
THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS SESSION.
AND WE HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL
SPECIAL GUEST WITH US IN THE
CHAMBER. MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE
YOUR ATTENTION TO MISTER HOLDEN.
MR HOLDING YOU HAVE SPECIAL
GUEST WITH US TODAY.
DO YOU THINK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I DO I'D LIKE TO.
.
RECOGNIZE THE SISTERS OF ALPHA
KAPPA ALPHA WHO ARE WITH US ON
THEIR LOBBY DAY A TODAY. THE
ALPHA KAPPA ALPHA SORORITIES
DEDICATION TO ADVOCACY.
THEIR DEDICATION TO ADVOCACY AND
SOCIAL CHANGE AS A MODEL FOR
SOCIAL ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS OUR
GREAT STATE.
I APPLAUD YOUR WORK ADVOCATING
FOR EDUCATING AND EMPOWERING
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY.
SO THANK YOU TO FOR ALL YOU DO.
AND WE COULD WE ARE APPRECIATING
IN RECOGNIZING MISS PATRICE
MARSHALL MACKENZIE LEGISLATIVE
LIAISON. MS LESLIE M. TEN SEN
CALIFORNIA STATE COORDINATOR
MISS CAROL R. DIXON FAR WESTERN
REGIONAL DIRECTOR. MRS CHARLOTTA
WILSON JACK'S
A KA INTERNATIONAL SECRETARY. MS
GAIL M. ATLEE FAR WESTERN
REPRESENTATIVE TO THE
INTERNATIONAL CONNECTION
COMMITTEE AND RENEE THEORY
JONES%
PROTOCOL OFFICER WELCOME ALL OF
.
THEY MISTER HOLDEN MEMBERS WE
WILL CONTINUE WITH THE REGULAR
ORDER OF BUSINESS WE ARE.
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE.
WE ARE AT SECOND READING.
THE CLERK WILL READ SO WE WILL
TWENTY THREE SEVEN SIX THREE
THOUSAND SEVEN NINETEEN NINETY
THREE SEVENTEEN SEVENTY TWENTY
TO FORTY NINE TWENTY TWO SIXTY
TWO WITH A MEMBERS TWENTY ONE
THIRTY SEVEN TWENTY SIX HUNDRED
TWENTY SIXTY FIVE TWENTY ONE
THIRTY TWO AMENDMENTS. TWENTY TO
SIXTY WITH A MEMBERS TWENTY
DEPRIVE THE MEMBERS TWENTY FIVE
NINETY EIGHT WITH THEM IS THIRTY
WANTED YOU TO THE MEMBERS TWENTY
SEVEN TEN TO MINUTES TWENTY FIVE
MINUTES TWENTY THIRTEEN OF THE
MINUTES. TWENTY NINE FORTY FOR
THE MEMBERS THIRTY ONE TWENTY
TWO MINUTES THIRTY ONE SEVEN
WITH A MINUTES TWENTY ARE SIXTY
WITH A MEMBERS TWENTY THREE
SEVEN ARE WITH A MINUTES. TWENTY
THREE FORTY ONE OF THE MEMBERS
NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR THE MINUTES
NINETEEN NINETY SIX FOR THE
MINUTES NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE
THE MINUTES TWENTY SEVEN
MINUTES.
TWENTY NINETY ONE OF THE MINUTES
TWENTY FOUR FORTY ONE OF THE
MEMBERS TWENTY SIX EIGHTY SIX OF
THE MEMBERS TWENTY TO THIRTY FOR
THE MEMBERS TWENTY EIGHT SIXTEEN
LIMITS. TWENTY SIX UP BEFORE THE
MEMBERS TWENTY TO TWENTY FIVE
THE MEMBERS TWENTY FORTY SEVEN
TO MEMBERS TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
THREE WITH A MINUTES. TWENTY ONE
TWENTY EIGHT WITH MEMBERS TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AMATUS TWENTY THREE
HER TEAM OF THE MINUTES TWENTY
SIX NINETY ONE OF THE MEMBERS
TWENTY ONE SEVEN ONE OF THE
MEMBERS. TWENTY SIX TWENTY WITH
A MINUTES TWENTY SIX WITH THE
ARM OF THE MEMBERS TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY TWO SOME BEFORE THE
MEMBERS AND ASSEMBLY OR.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS AND RETAIN.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIXTY FIVE.
MEMBERS.
WE HAVE REMAINING BUSINESS
BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY WERE FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIXTY FIVE THIS IS A
BE.
TWENTY TWO THIRTEEN FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS CARPOOL
READ WITH AMENDMENTS ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY TWO THIRTEEN WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOLEY.
MR KOHLI ON THE AMENDMENTS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
AMENDMENTS ON AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTEEN.
THIS BILL NARROWLY EXEMPTS
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT SECURITY COMPANIES.
WHO ARE ALREADY LICENSE TO CARRY
FIREARMS FROM THE FACE TO FACE
TRANSACTION REQUIREMENTS?
FOR AMMUNITION PURPOSES.
OF THE MEMBERS OF THE DESTITUTE
STATE CRIMINOLOGISTS OF THE
PARTNER JUSTICE.
IN THIS EXEMPTION IN THIS
EXEMPTION ALSO ADDED AN URGENCY
BECAUSE.
THE CHANGES HELP STREAMLINING
TERRIFIED THE PAPERWORK PROCESS.
THEREBY SUPPORTING LAW
ENFORCEMENT THOSE SECURITY
COMPANIES
TO COMPILE THREE SCHENECTADY
MISSION LAWS.
OUR QUESTION MINUTES BE ADOPTED
OUT TO PRINT AND BACK ON FILE.
THANK YOU AND MISTER CRAWLEY
SENIOR DISCUSSION BASED ON THESE
AMENDMENTS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED BILLS OUT TO PRINT.
AND BACK ON FILE.
FILE ITEMS SIXTY SIX.
SIXTY SEVEN SIXTY EIGHT PASS
RETAIN WE DISPENSE WITH FILE
ITEM SIXTY NINE. FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTY.
ALSO PASSED A RETAIN THAT BRINGS
US TO FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY
ONE.
THIS IS H. R. NINETY SEVEN BY
MISTER O'DONNELL THE CLERK WILL
READ.
HOUSE RESOLUTION NINETY SEVEN BY
SOME MEMORABLE DOLLAR ANOTHER
VILLAGE IF THE CAMBODIAN
GENOCIDE MEMORIAL WEEK.
SURE O'DONNELL. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I AM PLEASED
TO RESENT HR NINETY SEVEN WHICH
RECOGNIZES APRIL SIXTEENTH.
THROUGH APRIL TWENTIETH.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AS CAMBODIAN
GENOCIDE MEMORIAL WEEK.
FROM APRIL SEVENTEENTH NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE TO JANUARY SEVENTH
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE THE
COMMUTER ROUTES PERPETRATED ONE
OF THE GREATEST CRIMES.
OF THE TWENTIETH CENTURY.
NEARLY TWO MILLION PEOPLE DIED
UNDER THIS EXTREMIST RULE WHICH
IMPOSED A ROOTLESS AGENDA FORCED
LABOR. THOUGHT CONTROL AND MASS
EXECUTION UPON CAMBODIA.
AFTER THE OVERTHROW WITH RARE
ROUGE REGIME IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINE OVER ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY
THOUSAND CAMBODIANS CAME TO THE
UNITED STATES. AS REFUGEES.
MY COMMUNITY OF LONG BEACH IS
KNOWN AROUND THE WORLD US HOME
TO THE LARGEST CAMBODIAN
COMMUNITY OUTSIDE OF SOUTHEAST
ASIA.
THE CAMBODIAN PEOPLE HAVE DRAWN
FROM THEIR CULTURAL HISTORY TO
REBUILD THEIR LIVES AND
COMMUNITIES IN THIS STATE. AND
HAVE CONTRIBUTED GREATLY TO THIS
SOCIETY. AND LONG BEACH.
CAMBODIAN GENOCIDE MEMORIAL
WEEK.
HONORS THE SURVIVORS AND
DESCENDANTS FOR THEIR COURAGE
AND CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR STATE.
AND COUNTRY.
THANK YOU MISTER O'DONNELL.
SEEING NO.
YES.
TRY MISTER LEVINE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF HR NINETY SEVEN UP
MUCH LIKE.
I'VE VISITED CONCENTRATION
CAMPS IN EUROPE HAVE ALSO BEEN
TO CAMBODIA TO.
TO WITNESS
I PULL POTS.
KAMALA ROUGE IS A GENOCIDE ON
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT.
OF HIS COUNTRY'S TOTAL
POPULATION.
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OF THE WHOLE
COUNTRY'S POPULATION I KILLED IN
THAT GENOCIDE AND WHEN YOU LOOK
AT. THE HEIGHT OF THE GENOCIDE
THAT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT TODAY
THE HOLOCAUST IN IN WITH THE
CAMERA ROUGE COMMITTED ON THEIR
OWN COUNTRY YOU SEE ECHOES OF
TACTICS OF. OF MAKING MINORITIES
IN OTHERS LESS AYE THEN.
THAT THE DESIRED A GROUP THAT
THEY THEN DID DECIDE THAT THEY
ARE INFERIOR FROM AND THAT IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR US TO RECOGNIZE.
THIS GENOCIDE AND WITH THE
KHMER ROUGE DID IN AND I URGE MY
VOTE ON HR NINETY SEVEN THANK
YOU.
THINK MISS LEVINE MISTER BONTA.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU ME AND ISTER SPEAKER
AND COLLEAGUES AS CHAIR OF THE
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF HR NINETY SEVEN AND
THANK THE AUTHOR SINCE. I'M FROM
LONG BEACH FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
TODAY. MARKS THE START OF THE
CAMBODIAN NEW YEAR.
THE COMBINATION OF THREE DAYS OF
FESTIVITIES IN WHICH CAMBODIANS
ALL OVER THE WORLD CELEBRATE.
AND WELCOME THE NEW YEAR.
IT WAS THE DAY AFTER THESE NEW
YEAR CELEBRATIONS FORTY THREE
YEARS AGO THAT POL POT. AND THE
COME AYE RUCHED BEGAN THEIR
REGIME IN CAMBODIA ULTIMATELY
MURDERING ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION CAMBODIANS BY THE TIME
THE GENOCIDE AND DID. FOUR YEARS
LATER AN UNTOLD NUMBER OF OTHERS
WERE TORTURED RAPED AND WERE
WITNESSES TO MASS EXECUTIONS
ENTIRE FAMILIES INCLUDING YOUNG
CHILDREN. WERE FORCED INTO LABOR
CAMPS WITH ONLY SMALL RATIONS
OF WATERY RICE TO SUSTAIN THEM.
AFTER ESCAPING THE GENOCIDE MANY
CAMBODIANS FOUND A HOME IN
CALIFORNIA WHERE THEY HAVE
PERSISTED. THROUGH THE TRAUMA OF
WAR TO RAISE THEIR FAMILIES
ESTABLISHED COMMUNITIES AND
CONTRIBUTE.
TO THE DIVERSE FABRIC OF OUR
STATE.
THE GENOCIDE HAS LA LEFT A
LASTING IMPACT ON THE REFUGEES
FROM CAMBODIA AND THE
GENERATIONS THAT HAVE COME.
AFTER THEM AS POLICY LEADERS WE
MUST ENSURE THAT WE RECOGNIZE
AND ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE BEEN
AFFECTED BY WAR AND GENOCIDE. HR
NINETY SEVEN RECOGNIZES THE
IMPORTANCE OF COMMEMORATING
THOSE HORRIFIC EVENTS SO THAT WE
MAY HONOR THE LIVES OF THOSE WHO
ARE LOST AND STAY VIGILANT. TO
PREVENT THESE TRAGEDIES FROM
OCCURRING AGAIN.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
COLLEAGUES.
THANK YOU MISTER BONTA.
MISTER SPEAKER. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I TO WISH TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF HR NINETY
SEVEN I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LONG BEACH FOR
BRINGING THIS TO THE FLOOR. I'M
PROUD OF IT REPRESENT A PORTION
OF LONG BEACH AND REPRESENT
NORTH LONG BEACH WHICH AS HAS
BEEN MENTIONED HAS THE LARGEST
CAMBODIAN POPULATION OUTSIDE OF.
SOUTHEAST ASIA I WANT TO THANK
VERY PI CAUCUS CHAIR WHO VISITED
THE.
THAT LONG BEACH LAST YEAR ON
THIS PART OF HIS LISTING TO OUR
FOR THE API CAUCUS.
OUR CAMBODIAN COMMUNITY PLAYS A
VIBRANT ROLE IN OUR CULTURE IN
OUR ECONOMY AND THAT'S TRUE BOTH
FOR LONG BEACH IS WHILE THE
STATE IN GENERAL. THIS
RESOLUTION DOES A FEW IMPORTANT
THINGS FIRST OF ALL IT HONORS
THE STRENGTH AND RESILIENCE. OF
THOSE WHO CAME TO CALIFORNIA AS
REFUGEES FROM LONG BEACH
AND IT ALSO REMINDS US OF THE
HORROR OF THE CAMBODIAN GENOCIDE
THAT CAUSED SO MANY TO FLEE.
ONE IN FOUR THAT'S ROUGHLY THE
NUMBER OF CAMBODIANS WHO WERE
KILLED BY THE KHMER ROUGE
ONE IN FOR ALMOST TWO MILLION IN
TOTAL. AND THIS OCCURRED IN THE
LIFETIME OF MOST OF THE PEOPLE
IN THIS ROOM.
EARLIER TODAY IN ARE KEPT
COMMEMORATION OF THE HOLOCAUST
WE ONCE AGAIN SHARED THE VOW
NEVER AGAIN.
THERE CAN'T BE NEVER AGAIN
WITHOUT NEVER FORGET THIS
RESOLUTION HELPS ENSURE THAT WE
DON'T FORGET THE CAMBODIAN
GENOCIDE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MISTER O'DONNELL YOU MAY CLOSE
ON THE RESOLUTION IF YOU WISH
MISTAKE YOU FOR JOINING ME AND
RECOGNIZE THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF
THIS COURAGEOUS AND RESILIENT
COMMUNITY.
FLYING KNEES YANG TANG OSKAR
HERE CARE CHAT COMPARE.
BUT TODAY WE ARE ALL CAMBODIAN.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AND REQUEST THAT THE FIRST WILL
BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
MEMBERS THE OFFICE ASSN THE
FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
COOPER'S ON HR NINETIES.
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS MEMBERS.
CLERK WILL. CLOSE THE ROLE THERE
ARE SEVENTY TWO COAUTHORS ADDED
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT HOUSE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
FILE ITEM SEVENTY TWO AND
SEVENTY THREE PASS AND RETAIN
THAT MOVES US TO CONSENT
CALENDAR.
THE ANY MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND A
CONSENT CALENDAR.
SO MANY WILL FOR THIRTY ONE
TWENTY FOUR BY SOME MEMBER WOMAN
ACCOLADE OF VEHICLES.
CLARK RUBBED THE WRONG. COUNTER
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MEMBERS THIS IS CAN SEND
CALENDAR.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL.
I SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED
IN THE CLERK WILL READ THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ASSUMING GO NINETEEN
SIXTY.
I SEVENTY TWO. NO ZERO.
MEMBERS MOVING BRIEFLY BACK TO
GUEST INTRODUCTIONS MISTER
O'DONNELL YOU HAVE SOME GAS IN
THE CHAMBER RELATIVE TO YOUR
RESOLUTION JUST PRESENTED ON THE
FLOOR MISTER O'DONNELL. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED YEAH I THINK YOU ARE
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ON
BEHALF OF SPEAKER RENDON AND
MYSELF.
I WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME LEADERS
FROM THE CAMBODIAN COMMUNITY IN
LONG BEACH THAT HAVE JOINED US
IN THE GALLERY TODAY. AND
RECOGNITION OF CAMBODIAN
GENOCIDE MEMORIAL WE.
THEY MAKE CALIFORNIA THEY MAKE
LONG BEACH A BETTER PLACE PLEASE
WELCOME
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS MISTER CALDERON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
ANNOUNCEMENT.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
JUST AS A REMINDER TODAY AT
THREE PM WILL WE WILL BE
SWEARING IN OUR NEW COLLEAGUE.
MISS CAMELOT OR DUBBED I'M WE
ARE WELCOME ALL OF YOU TO
PARTICIPATE HOWEVER THEY'RE
GOING TO BE COMMITTEES THAT ARE
GONNA BE COMMENCING AT THE SAME
TIME. AND ALL WE ASK IS THAT IF
YOU ARE A COMMITTEE THAT YOU DO
STATE COMMITTEE SO THAT WE CAN
GET THAT WORK DONE BUT FOR THOSE
OF YOU THAT ARE NOT IN
COMMITTEE.
PLEASE COME BACK TO FOUR THREE
THREE EIGHT PM TO SWEAR IN OUR
NEW COLLEAGUE.
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON
MEMBERS ALL REQUESTS TO THE
JOURNEY MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED
READ PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
TUESDAY APRIL SEVENTEENTH CHECK
IN SESSION. WEDNESDAY APRIL
EIGHTEENTH CHECK IN SESSION.
THURSDAY APRIL NINETEENTH. FLOOR
SESSION IS AT NINE A. M. ALL
OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE
PASSED RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL
BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN MISTER
CALDERON MOVES AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS.
THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL THURSDAY APRIL NINETEENTH
AT NINE AM IN THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED